hmm so good i want a cheeseburger this
is a special soup called
pho you told me not to say that word
it is delicious this is the food of your
people
can i get you anything else actually um
we're just trying to teach our daughter
about your country and as i'm saying
that i'm hoping you're from vietnam
i was born there so was lily oh it's a
beautiful country
uh my family still lives there i hate
vietnam lily honey we don't hate
i hate vietnam
okay oh we need just a second lily that
was rude
i want to go home no it's important that
you celebrate the culture of your
ancestors
you are vietnamese no i'm not i'm gay
i'm
gay honey no you're not gay you are just
confused oh my god what is wrong with me
it's like
oh please we have tons of lesbian
friends bob that you would reference our
friends and not us
okay we should just go no nobody's going
anywhere until she finishes the whole
soup no gloria it's fine no no it's not
fine that's the problem with this
country nobody cares where they come
from they just want cheeseburgers
and prep school and they have forgotten
about colombia
okay i can't help but feel that maybe
you're bringing something to the table
that's possibly
uh not at all about lily i think you're
right
it's just that i feel like i'm losing my
children to america
they're just going to grow up and become
boring old white people
oh most of our friends are white
actually
okay can everybody just calm down and go
back to their own conversations just
thank you hey hey what's going on with
you
manny has forgotten most of his spanish
and yo i'm sure he's not even going to
learn it
i know this is silly but i just don't
like feeling like i'm so different from
the rest of my family
oh honey he feels so lonely wait just a
second
lily is that why you want to be gay to
be more like your daddies
oh honey no the three of us are a family
even though we come from different
places you know you were born in vietnam
and
i grew up in a city and even though he
never talks about it your daddy grew up
on a farm
the point is is that we're a family
because we love each other
okay and you know what you just caused a
scene in the restaurant
and you can't get any more like your
daddies than that
maybe i'll just take manny and joe to
colombia this summer i think that's a
great idea
i really think that keeping in touch
with their heritage only enriches our
culture
absolutely i think we would all be
better off if people would go back to
where they came from
i i'll pull the car around yes
you